To steal from the empire
you just walk in like you belong they're
so proud of themselves so fat and satisfied
they can't imagine that someone like
me would ever get inside their house
cassian ander the empire is choking us
so slowly we're starting not to notice
what i'm asking is this wouldn't you
rather give it all to something real
i need all the heroes i can
get for the greater good
call it what you will let's call it war
it's fermenting out there
some pockets of fermenting
you're in my net
are you a fish or are you a thief
you're slipping i'm not slipping
i've just been hiding for too long
as long as everyone thinks i'm an irritation
there's a good chance they'll miss what
i'm really doing what are you really doing
this is what revolution looks like
i'm tired of losing
Welcome back everyone this will be my new
star wars and or trailer video there's a
bunch of easter eggs they also made a couple
big announcements in the trailer too about
when they're shifting the premiere day so we'll
break it all down i'll be doing videos for all
the episodes just like i do for the other star
wars disney plus series so be sure to subscribe
to get them all now confirmed that the first
couple of episodes are dropping september 21st
they pushed it a couple weeks so that it doesn't
overlap with the she-hulk episodes quite as much
i always thought it was weird they were dropping
two really huge series with long runs right on
top of each other like why are you doing that to
yourself shield episodes are going to start in a
couple weeks it'll run for nine episodes star
wars and or is actually 12 episodes so that's
why they're dropping the first three episodes on
premiere day it'll still run for like 10 weeks i
just did a big video for the mandalorian season 3
trailer so i'll link that below in the description
that'll be starting in early february it'll be
like the next big star wars series after andor
we also have the star wars ahsoka episodes which
will be starting next spring that'll be after the
mandalorian season 3 but that'll be a mandalorian
spin-off during the same part of the timeline as
the mandalorian episodes i also did a separate
ahsoka trailer video so i'll link that below
in the description as well as i said in my last
andor trailer video this is meant to be a prequel
to rogue one it's set about five years before
the events of rogue one and it'll just show the
formation of the rebellion it'd become more of
the actual rebellion by the time of rogue one
the story of that movie literally being them
stealing the death star plans many bothans died
also a lot of the characters that will meet in
this series most notably cassian andor one of the
other cool connections with characters like ahsoka
and anakin skywalker is that cassie and andor also
went by the code name fulcrum just like anakin
skywalker did during the clone wars and then
later ahsoka and callum during star wars rebels
the events of star wars rebels kind of bump up
against the events of rogue one because it takes
place around that same time after the rebellion
has already formed but star wars rebels was a
little bit earlier in the timeline of the actual
rebellion so there's a little bit of overlap
here with a couple exceptions of the really big
characters like mod mothma who you've seen many
times before in the star wars movies in star wars
rogue one most of these characters are meant to
be relatively new especially some of the imperial
characters right now it seems like the biggest
ones are going to be stellan skarsgard's lutheran
character who seems like mon mothma like another
really big powerful figure inside the empire
who's critical in the formation of the rebellion
because it seems like he's the person who winds up
recruiting casting and or in the first place you
also see him with a couple different hairstyles so
it kind of denotes this time change that happens
during the series when he's meeting mon mothma
on coruscant his chambers just seemed way nicer
his clothes everything about it just seems like
his normal imperial trappings here but then later
in the trailer when you see him on this scrapyard
planet when he's recruiting cassie and andor
he's got the short haircut and he doesn't have
any attendance with him so it just seems like even
more than mod mothma does he goes on the dl trying
to actually form the rebellion itself but as far
as we know we actually don't see him during the
events of star wars rogue one so early rip warning
on his character like he actually might wind up
getting killed during the events of the series
the other interesting thing you'll notice is
that it's the same actress who came back to play
mon mothma she's the same actress who played her
when she was much younger during the events of the
star wars prequel we know from long-running star
wars canon she was critical in the formation of
the rebellion as one of the more powerful figures
along with princess leia like princess leia was
actually really critical in the formation of the
rebellion too so i'm wondering if we're gonna
see another younger version of her character
who's just a little bit older than we saw her
during the star wars obi-wan kenobi series
that would be like one of the other big surprises
of the series because we didn't really see her
during the star wars obi-wan kenobi trailers they
kind of kept that secret to the first couple of
episodes dropped because she and luke are twins
they're the same age they were meant to be around
the age of 18 during star wars a new hope i think
this would make her about 13 years old during the
events at the beginning of this series but
because the events of the series will take
place over the course of five years she might wind
up showing up in the later episodes where she's
just like a little bit older and she becomes
an imperial senator i think that happened when
she was around 16 years old so we'll see if she
winds up popping up somewhere later in the series
even though we didn't see him in this trailer
i believe that bail organa is also going to pop
up during this series as well because he was also
critical in the formation of the rebellion as well
i think they were mostly using this trailer
to just introduce you to a lot of the brand
new characters along with a couple of the
familiar characters like obviously darth
vader the inquisitors were very active during this
period so we'll see what they're doing during this
part of the timeline all the inquisitor characters
that you saw during obi-wan kenobi who are still
alive at the end of that series like the grand
inquisitor is still alive during this part of
the timeline and still very active they don't say
exactly where this planet is when they pick up in
the trailer it might be fest because i think
we're meant to see a young version of cassie
and andor basically infiltrating the empire on
his own and trying to sabotage them from within
before the actual formation of the rebellion like
he's kind of acting on his own doing his own thing
until lutheran's character comes to find
him and recruit him for the actual rebellion
they open by combining a couple familiar star
wars tropes so you open with like a star destroyer
entering from above just showing you how huge
it is but in the trailer it's entering the
atmosphere like you saw during rogue one like star
destroyer inside a planet's atmosphere it sounds
like this imperial scrapyard planet is going to
be a big part of the series like this is where
the town is that we see later in the trailer
it also seems like it's where the facilities
underground are where they're building stuff using
the scrap metal i think the idea is they're just
using it as a critical facility in their supply
chain to build more weapons just using scrap from
other things that have been destroyed it's not
totally clear but the way they're presenting this
trailer footage this is young cassie and andor
slowly infiltrating the empire and he's making
this joke about how easy it is for you to just
waltz into the empire and become this saboteur
as you see this little kid who might be casting
and or just walking into this imperial facility
this seems pretty critical we get a shot at the
imperial senate on coruscant it seems like a lot
of the series is going to take place there a lot
of you will recognize anton lesser he was maester
qyburn on game of thrones now it seems like he's
an imperial admiral residing over this group of
admirals inside the imperial security bureau
i think that's what the white uniforms were
meant to denote because you see a couple white
uniforms throughout the trailer that's the same
group the director krennic's character was part
of he was in charge of building the death star
the imperial security bureau is also the arm of
the empire that moff gideon on the mandalorian
rose up through so that's obviously later in
the timeline he's become a moth by that point
but at this point of the timeline he's
probably just like another officer
inside the imperial security bureau i don't know
if he's supposed to have any cameos during this
this woman in the white imperial security bureau
uniform is called demiro and it seems like she's
arresting adrian aroha's character here who you
recognize from a lot of other things she seems
like somebody who has a relationship with cassie
and andorra's character early on and they just
try to interrogate her for more information on
this quote-unquote resistance that's forming
another big surprise here is that when you see the
x-wing you also get reintroduced to saw gerrera's
character he comes back obviously it's a younger
version of the character that we saw during rogue
one he doesn't have quite as many city miles on
him like he isn't rasping through that breathing
device i believe they also brought a much younger
version of the character back during the bad batch
series which takes place like right after the
events of revenge of the sith as a character he's
basically meant to represent the more militant
arm of the rebellion like the one that's way more
hardcore than most of the other rebels like he
literally says the word war when he's talking to
luthen's character here we see more of the empire
wearing their riot gear in this town on that
same scrapyard planet a lot of you asking if this
character is meant to be starkiller if you look at
the subtitles here it says sergeant linus mosque
so clearly not meant to be starkiller i think
it's mostly just because he looks very similar to
sam whitworth but it's not sam where it's like a
completely different actor i think the idea with
his character because you see him a couple times
in the other trailer too is that he's meant to
be someone in the empire who has sort of second
thoughts about what's going on and eventually
might wind up being like a callous figure in star
wars rebels who eventually you find out is helping
the rebellion this is meant to be on coruscant i
think this is also meant to be on coruscant with
the imperial shuttle when you see the scene with
mod mothma meeting with the other senators here at
this party this character actually seems kind of
like matt ryan who played constantine in the
arrowverse for many many years the character
that mon mothma is talking to isn't meant to be
chancellor valorum but it does look similar to him
you see more of the black stormtroopers those are
the death troopers that we saw during rogue one
those are flamethrowers that they're holding
everyone will recognize fiona shaw from the
harry potter films it seems like in this series
she's also playing an important character in the
formation of the rebellion on this scrapyard
planet like she's one of the higher up figures
inside the rebellion this red droid they were
actually showing off at comic con his name is b2
emo just like with a lot of the other droids in
star wars that they introduced like during the
obi-wan kenobi series they'll probably be selling
this as merch pretty soon if they aren't already
this is another new character called clea i
don't know who this actress is she seems kind of
familiar but she just seems like another character
who's important within the rebellion then you see
a scene of cassie and andor and the rebels looking
like they're trying to infiltrate an imperial
facility on this same scrapyard planet all these
scenes in the white area underground just seems
like where they're actually processing a lot of
this scrap metal into new weapons then they show
you a montage of a bunch of different fight scenes
i think just going crazier and crazier towards the
end of the series but like i said the whole idea
is that this is meant to be like a two-season
series of about 24 episodes total i believe and
it's just meant to show you the formation of the
actual rebellion so like in the series finale
at the end of season two next year for example
it'll be like right at the beginning of rogue
one if you spotted any big easter eggs in the
trailer that i didn't talk about in the video just
write them below in the comments there was another
brand new she-hulk trailer that just dropped this
morning so i'll try to do a video for that as fast
as possible to make sure you enable alerts for
my channel so you don't miss that my she-hulk
episode videos will start in a couple weeks though
that'll be the first thing to drop everyone click
here for my brand new guardians of the galaxy 3
trailer with a first look at adam warlock and a
bunch of new footage and click here for my brand
new she-hulk trailer and ghost rider easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!